this is a piece of the world's first
business computer as it from IBM
hewlett-packard Microsoft know they were
beaten to it by Jade lions and coal a
company better known for making cakes
and if history had gone a little
differently you might be watching this
on a Leo in 1950 if you fancy a cup of
tea or a slice of cake then here's a
good place a Lyons tea shop that looks
like it's from another era and so it is
the future you see behind the quaint
exterior Lyons is building a new breed
of worker it all starts when they hear
that mathematicians in Cambridge England
are creating an electronic brain could
such a thing crunch numbers for a
catering Empire Lyons cut a deal they'll
help fund the research in return for a
working model three years later
leo is born this is state-of-the-art
1950s IT small enough to fit on a single
floor of lions head office it's mercury
based memory can be a touch mercurial
but when it's firing it holds a full two
kilobytes of information or a biocide to
pay for okay not much processing power
by 21st century standards but in 1951
it's more than you'll find inside any
other business and the world and enough
to seriously power up the process of
selling tea and cakes every morning tea
shop manager s is across the country
ring head office with their orders for
cakes scones and sandwiches they are fed
into Leo who converts them into binary
digest the information and spits out the
orders to be delivered to the tea shops
but the genius of Leo is that it's not
fussy about its empire that can process
just about anything
from tea blends to pagal calculating a
payslip used to take 8 minutes now it
takes 1.5 seconds for management that's
a revolution no need to rely on gut
instinct when they've got
up-to-the-minute analysis from leo
bigger firms start to take notice and
buy time on Leo to do their own
computations Kodak Ford even the
top-secret nuclear weapons program Blue
Streak but Lions are thinking ahead if
everyone wants their computer why not
sell computers they set up Leo computers
limited to build more advanced machines
until a British catering firm is poised
to become the world's first IT giant
course that's not quite how it turns out
Leo can process any kind of business but
businesses can't process the idea of
buying computers from lions in the end
the Americans catch up and overtake and
it's IBM who take over the world market
in business computers Leo computers is
swallowed up and two other companies
it's pioneering days behind them
of course it's legacy remains the
information age now part of office life
[Music]